how you doing I'm good tired I'm good
how are you uh good your new album has
been out for a couple of weeks now how's
it feel it feels good I think we're
approaching our second week right now so
are you feeling like you know like I
feel like when the albums drop it's like
the work just begins yeah you got to do
all the running around and yeah it's a
lot this is actually like New York Press
was crazy Atlanta press was kind of
crazy but you know at kind of more
subtle more chill yeah yeah uh for
people who don't know you're from okay
you rep Jersey but you you grew up in
New York give me the bre give a little
bit of both yeah definitely so um Early
Childhood in New York and then I moved
to Jersey and the high school there so
so you Jersey yeah what part East orang
okay I've only been I went to uh what
part of Jersey do we go to Jersey City
yeah not too far we were in uh what's
the name of that rapper that we shot
with oh uh he put honey he put a honey
pack in his honey bun hold on now he
just got he just got out of prison [__]
I forget yes oh yeah yeah Jersey Jersey
City we went to like his corner store
and um he did the most wild [__] he took
like the mail enhancer honey pack yeah
and he put it in his in his food be
whing that's crazy shout out to Jersey
though man yeah there was the honey bun
and the Honey pack combo who would have
thought that was crazy um so your new
album's called Soul yeah what's the
acronym stand for signs of universal
love okay yeah I like that yeah it's a
Vibe it's all about zodiac signs so it's
like you believe in zodiac signs huh I
believe that they govern your
temperament I don't swear by them I
always you know I didn't really I'm
going a I I almost call myself an aqu
that's an outcast album I an aquarius
got it but I don't know what that means
yeah I mean you can be often detached
you can be kind of aloof I feel like um
it's many qualities of an aquarius but
of course it all has to do with your
other placements too your moon sign your
rising sign that that's all important to
I'm curious will you like let's say if
there's somebody in your life or let's
say in your past have you not
entertained somebody because of their
sign absolutely 100% so you believe for
real I believe that it controls certain
elements of you and it's no it's like
that can't be no coincidence that all
y'all act like that like n so if you
going to like like let's say have you
ever gone on a date with somebody found
out there zodiac sign and been like oh
this would be the last date yep wow I
didn't know people like that what's nice
to meet somebody like that cuz I always
thought that that was like a myth no I
mean I wouldn't say my last dat but I
would be like I'm cautious you're
cautious yeah I be like cuz like if
everything lines up that's good but then
they but they were born in the wrong
month it's like damn I'm telling you
something coming every time every time
so what is your zodiac son I'm a cancer
what's what I don't know what that means
we're the mother of the zodiac I'm very
nurturing very uh sensitive hyper
sensitive and super moody which uh sign
are you not
coer with uh Libras Libras yeah Libras
are psychopaths interesting characters
for I think great friendships though
like I have good friendships with my uh
my son's mom is a Libra and uh both of
my sons are Libras and uh oh wow yeah
wow that's a heavy household the
toxic a toxic sign yeah is that accurate
me saying that out Libras are a little
toxic toxic manipulative victimizing
Jesus but also Super Creative mhm um
very very good at what they do they do
something they do at the best you know
okay I say that about them for sure
shout out to the uh Libras out there so
if you if so if someone's born in
October they're just done in your or
late September I have I don't have no
pics they're toasted way wow shout out
to you